hey this is presto Walker a math teacher
is buying wooden letters each letter has
a price but different letters can have
different prices a shopkeeper explains
the cost of a few words one cost one
dollar two costs two dollars and 11
costs $11 the math teacher wants to buy
12
how much does 12 cost can you figure it
out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
we will convert this problem into
algebraic equations the letters for the
word 100 sin plus e together cost $1 the
same thing is true for Q the letters T
plus W plus o equal their cost of $2
also the letters of xi together cost $11
we need to solve for the cost of the
letters of 12 how can we do that we
could try and manipulate these equations
to figure out clever cancellations in
fact there is a wonderful anagram that
can help us solve this problem the
phrase 2 plus 11 exactly can be
rearranged to the phrase 1 plus 12 it's
quite an amazing thing that these
letters of 2 plus 11 can be rearranged
to equal 1 plus 12
this kind of anagram is very interesting
and it will help us solve this problem
what's further special about this is the
phrase 1 plus 12 and 2 plus 11 both have
13 letters and the answer to each phrase
is 13 you could either have the anagram
of the numerals 2 + 1 1 + 1 + 1 2 to be
the anagram of numerals
so now let's use this to solve the
problem we know that 2 plus 11 equals 1
plus 12 in terms of each of the letters
in each of the words we were given the
cost that one equals $1 2 equals 2
dollars and 11 equals 11 dollars so we
know that the letters 4 12 will follow
this algebraic equation so we could
subtract $1 from both sides to get that
12 costs
exactly $12 so that's the answer
12 costs $12 and it is the world's
easiest problem because you might have
been able to guess it without even going
through all the algebra did you figure
it out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Walker and if you like
this video please check out my books
there are links in the video description